welcome to this video playing step by
step here with white yeah one of those
frequent opponents that I have a totally
Scrappy's go against what did I have
five and a half out of 18 that's not
much okay let's see what we get yeah
he's playing this the super risky Kings
Indian line where black is abandoning
the whole Queen side and but um the itis
it is complicated I'd have six that's
that's how how you play it have 494 yeah
I recently recently lost a game in that
line not with Bishop age 6 I don't think
that this is so great actually but ok it
loses quite some time from like he gets
rid of his bishop but it loses lots of
time ok so mm-hmm Queen and there's
queen bee three that's the captcha ok I
don't want to spend too much time nine
to be 598 this can also just take he i
am and i should probably do that it's
what idea of queen bee three check ok so
rook do one-on-one but what rook exactly
let's let's take this work not sure now
the d file open it's not so clear what
is king side off enzyme is going to if
this is going to be m very dangerous yep
okay let's trade that ok 95 he asked
what Queen f7 maybe and it didn't okay
I'll again I can still play that I got
Quincy 39 takes I it's not leading to
two very much
um
John don't have anything anything great
it looks it looks okay for white but I
don't have anything special I would like
to get the night to see for now is this
possible it's very slow it's a very slow
maneuver now i'm wondering if i can get
this in night be 1d to see for it it's
as mentioned it is slow okay let's try
that I might have a five now now that
was stupid 85 now yeah yeah very simple
but I only saw it after after I moved
Queenie to that's very awkward from a
good position to a bad one in one move
and i know i always play badly against
the sky I always do I don't know why
it's kind of strange yeah and now he has
definitely summer Taking Chances I mean
I don't think that the h5 was any good
but now he has a taking chances okay so
let's see ya the 60 probably just will
take
takes Knight takes Queen edge voices
coming really quickly yeah it's just
awkward just a just a bad position we
can take take before 97 and that's it
probably ok then b7 hangs no maybe yeah
I what a bad game what a bad game I
totally killed myself here with a
chiffon
and I can just go Queen Queen d2
probably now here I can take on g4 at
least it's still probably good Queen d2
I don't know ok at least I get here
after him probably you can just take
them yeah check them try to go to each 0
to cover the crucial defiled squares
okay yeah yeah I think he still has to
find something something good probably
there is something but it's nothing
completely obvious to me d 5 and before
is both hanging so after king e 2 i'm
threatening to take both both of those
pawns and if he's not checkmating me
this is not so bad
I meet some stupid makes mistakes that
we can do be interesting I know about 95
was a was actually a mistake I should
have played that differently so Queen
Queen c3 or be too no it's not mattering
much doesn't matter very much I will
take a for next anyway I hope I should
have taken on d6 first and then only
then play on and play the 95 move ok so
i think i'm just taking up if i move the
light you will come to deform they don't
want that so how to play here it's not
so not so easy Jack Queen g8 entering
shouldn't be bad well maybe he gets
counted player possible can take g3 or I
can give a couple of checks for a check
trying to take things with chicken check
check time working yeah can I take an
even more with checking i think i'm
chatting to this back here to cover
stuff
black reason yeah i was a bit lucky of
course i was i was completely completely
toasted down a hall was ridiculously
ridiculously bad i made some mistakes
them here's the first one here i have to
take on the six this is what I what came
to me later I have to take here first
and then take that is much better in
comparison because now the sea pawns are
traded which makes this can transition
of you if you look at this here takes
takes this this is much better in
comparison now as the sea file is open I
actually have 95 and here white is
better it's king is weakened let's say
here and now i can think of various
things i can also just go back looking
at this pawn and this is good for white
but in the game i well i had the idea
with queen bee three so i played it
immediately but this is not as strong
and the comp is actually giving b5 as
even stronger intending b6 maybe but the
computers tending to overestimate the
white position very much in those kind
of positions the computer sees the huge
space and doesn't really appreciate the
long term attack that black off and
hares okay Jesus this is not bad or
anything but it's not leading to much
maybe Bishop c4 was superficial actually
here I have the chance to play 95 here
and then then back something like that
that could be interesting or just just
look now there should be six Queens III
this is kind of thing looking at this
pawn yeah I'm also a little bit better
here
but the way I played it there was
nothing really this is this is ok I
think yeah I did not play naive or is it
is totally totally do tech I was
thinking here but I thought Queen f7
would be good I overlooked many things
him c6 is good for what I was thinking
Queen f7 and he would play c6 next but
of course I play c6 myself yeah that's
also quite nice for what ok a force not
only then not taking the 95 opportunity
but it's also stupid because it runs
into this a 5 idea I have to I totally
ignore this and here 85 is just yeah
that just ok from like probably I mean
it's better for him I mean the question
is how much better it is yeah I didn't
see anything else than this and this is
completely ridiculous here now he gets
in all or gets in all this year for free
trade straight yeah and Jack we have to
maybe yeah this is this is what the
computers addressed suggests enter and
over on the edge file now it looks good
but after what he did isn't this ok as
well isn't this sufficient 19 2 g-3 whom
yeah g3 looks normal but computer wants
to take but I wonder the way it went I
mean I cannot believe black ass worse
this is really not after that he is vers
iam
yeah this is what the engine is
suggesting for Queen deform yeah it's
not an easy move to make am giving away
b7 with check but it wins it does win
chanting this wins for black according
to the comp yeah there are tons of
checks and if the g2 porn forts there
will be a new queen yeah this was then
winning Queen deform he went he went or
b3 he went he took one minute and played
in 98 yeah I probably miscalculated
something there it's not easy after that
yeah the tables have turned here white
is better in fact clearly better stock
fishes on plus one already yeah I
suspected that much i will get before 85
is weak this is kind of this is what
happens it's nothing that he can do
about it check and shank think I screw
jack to bed yeah it looks that yes looks
quite okay be 66 and 26s is over yeah
that was lucky of course but interesting
it especially am that in the opening I
have to insert this I have to invert
this this straight on the six this is
really better and it's interesting to
see what the comp does here by the way
computer wants to play this b6 takes
takes Queen B 498a for Ruby f7 and the
computer gives 1 plus five or so for
white but look at this I mean this is
not so easy if why this what is mike
going to do it's going to go 85 okay
okay i'm wearing h5 txtx 94 okay maybe
there are tactics am like rook be eight
and now Knight b6 as possible somehow
this is possible yeah okay there are
some tactics maybe maybe you're crashing
through where
black is somewhat slow here I understand
but you have to be very very cautious
with the comp evaluations in Kings
Indian type of position they sometimes
give completely unclear positions and
the computer give it +1 or something
like that and this is not the case
especially in practical chess ok well
thanks for watching